bene arresto per non aver messo un like
questo video ciao nuovo talent con
vitale come sempre per completare ciao
visione possibile veramente come su che
perfezione insomma la mente consigliata
poi nei commenti grazie video traver me
l'ha consigliata e cioè andremo a fare
lo strum bar ammanettati
ma non solo perché dobbiamo vedere chi
riesce a fare lo slam prima atp che ce
la prendiamo troppo con calma
quindi recati nello studente primo ha un
punto in più e poi anche i punti di
deciderete voi come sempre dovrete
votare per bellezza e persone dello
spray una cosa che cela il migliore sono
invece hanno questa volta con se non hai
la fortuna delle casualità del rondò
riposo insieme per stavolta s'è vista
per fare quindi mi raccomando lasciate
un bel like su questo video
scriveteci pure in un medico riapprezza
le bollette che facciamo sia adesso
avete scritto anche di fare da 24 ore o
manica socialismo penso che impazziremo
ma vediamo prima ora da questa per
questo bamber e magari possiamo provare
a serio pericolo come ad esempio di
patatine concorde mettetevi comodi il
video tutto schermo è iniziato
allora andiamo a mettere le mani se vi
dico già che prima società di aprirla e
18 già una chiave che ne rimane solo 16
arricciarsi ohio e il mio crimine parli
troppo perché stata vista già vende
melbourne 3 2 1 via possiamo scegliere
tutto a casa ad aspettare perché volete
un altra regola che fin troppo facile
solo questa mano la mano destra per fare
lo slime mano ammanettata per fare mora
ha imposto sono sinistro non solo pasto
ed il caso fiat e questo a mio ti faccio
male non può che abbiamo esterno alla
destra per me è ok tre due uno via
[Musica]
l'altro
ciao guarda che prima di finirla ma che
mi perché morì milano la trasparenza
così sempre però che anche questa volta
che vuole buttare quello trasparente
pianta vediamo mischiandosi
due gol che basti questa notizia
[Musica]
allora quello di mettere un pochino
piccolo grande il colore va elogiato e
questo perché quando il credito
cerco di non guardare anche a sorpresa
[Musica]
il sito troppo non si credono in
istituti mi riterrò grafiti guarigione
di queste qua sopra
questi enormi problemi di tutti guai a
te guai a stesse pressioni per tutti
sono questi ma ora aspetta da lì che
dobbiamo questo non si rompe tutto che
ha fatto rischiare un bene primario per
il freddo in mano dei prezzi alla fine
del processo frantumi tengono sotto
l'inter fino
ma guardare misto del brano sbagliato e
non banali contro ratificare bara
aspetto come andrà questa una ma devi
usare
[Applauso]
[Musica]
un po il polso del mezzo tanto di
offerta s'è ribellata alla vetta
il nodo tecnico lazio
dormo bene cos'è come ieri con l'altra
mano si tiene il rapporto tra mantenere
i padri che dovrà spazio a prenderla
genere a siete pieni ecco è complicato
adesso che continuando così la strana
perché mai fumato
non è facile lo stesso vedremo quel tram
bello ok quando pensi che ti hanno
formato da cui mia scolare con le mani
che non si forma per falco sempre
steinmann dedita poi dopo devo andare a
trovare chi vai e ti porto con me ne
fece mia e di bellissimo e la palette
d'addio già sono forma perché aperto la
tira messeri a rettori e sotto a
pezzettoni europee così che è messo bene
cosa bellissima allora è finito proviamo
adesso fatemi vedere bene così potete
votare anche piancavallo buffa dello
stesso nel bottino
io un po dove vai o coloro che ora ve le
facciamo vedere meglio vi spieghiamo
anche progetto allora vedere dopo
aspetta beh io sto facendo comunque
sempre con le manette
questo è lo slime che ho fatto e menate
che tipo di sly man è un jolly cubes
line che mese così mi sembrano il mango
quindi il mango
un paio che si toglie al quadro simile
questione di geni clip che ho fatto ho
usato il colore giallo non troppo però
messo tipo un paio di gocce di giallo
infatti un po più scuro poi ho messo i
brillantini viola quelli grandi però
vedete che ridimensioni po più grande
e poi ho messi presenti nizar li stritti
in due lati nizar lì per dargli un
effetto dorato infatti è un po dorato e
poi ovviamente le spugnette dentro per
fare le foto del gel in cube quindi da
teli in moto di affetto e ora vi faccio
sentire i suoni
[Musica]
mi sembra stia suonando 4 fitto
propositi dopo tocca a te siamo
incollati cosa fare
fermo the coprendo tutti il solito le
manette
cosa ci sia bel riflesso dorato mi
raccomando commentare questa volta l'ha
vinto vitale vip finito quindi dategli
pure un voto per aspetto e per suoni
scrivetelo nei commenti
e ora partiamo il tuo contento contento
vorrei dire ma guardate che bella
elastico il colore soprattutto questo
rosa questo rosa giovanile questa rosa
delicato giovane delicato come si
estende con si espande su di torna
adesso lo mettiamo qui ci facciamo un
bel rotolino perché accade ora le
bellissimo bellissimo sentiamo un po di
suoni e senza fare una fattura unità che
esco dal io ho 14 ore fa sentire i suoi
interrotto lo stato dell'arte bellissimo
duro vi sembra in contrasto con il rosa
ci sono questi si chiamano questi questi
flake se non si provvede chiusa città
e poi ancora più contrasto queste queste
stelline verbi che in realtà si vedono
già allenato un verdi una bellissima poi
ci sono dei piccoli e piccole palline
birthday cake piccole colline per dei
gay stati e bellissimo bellissimo perché
è bello morbido si stende sentire rumori
quanti romani fa mi raccomando votate
brilla di più questo questo un pezzo d
oro 24 carati per ciri pronto attaccati
l'opera aperto un polmone
quanto è bello colpito qualche bello
votate
vi raccomando mi raccomando scrivete mi
dispiace anni da questa volta di più
vitale voglio vedervi così il commento
andy che mi riguarda tutti aspetta
aspetta aspettate
ora dobbiamo cercare di liberarsi usando
l'unica chiave è rimasto questa mini
chiave per colpa due è generata una ma
il terzino non è colpa mia comunque che
facciamo a sproposito così provveduto
rispettato dell'incastro allora pazze
che il buco della chiave vedetta chiave
quinti
il momento sembra senso penso che vada
così quella chiave tempo però impresa
difficile si avvia in malissimo
ok ok troppo sta che va dentro qualche
contenuto stilate chiama l'anno rompere
pure questa non ho paura non è tutto
[Musica]
perché lei bicicletta nome non ce la fa
niente rimaniamo per teatro male tasti
ma senza 6 1 titolo una modalità governo
dovrà esser malato si apra che dire la
chiave
beh ragazzi votate nei commenti se ho
vinto io sono vinto italo in base ai
voti che avete letto
fateci sapere se volete un'altra azione
john manetas iscrivete insicure nei
commenti che tipo di challenge che
challenge e ora vi lasciamo qua 4
quadratini sotto potete cliccare per
vedere le nostre altre challenge
possibili e divertenti in his life
quello che volete cliccate se quella che
preferite e buona visione
ciao
[Musica]